[Music]
things like
you know that voice and you certainly
know that song that is Jewel her hit
song you remember this you were meant
for me she's a four-time Grammy nominee
who's known for her dedication of mental
health May is mental health awareness
month were you aware of that we were and
we are continuing our Wellness week
series with conversations on that very
topic that's right and her Memoir never
broken Jewel writes about her own mental
health struggles and she's also now an
advocate helping create the inspiring
Children's Foundation For at-risk Youth
and more recently inner world of virtual
reality Wellness Center Gail and I
talked with Jewel just yesterday and
here is our conversation
welcome welcome it's so great to have
you here uh and you know as a guy in his
room age 14 in the 90s listening to that
music I mean I was having a mental
health moment myself it helped me get
through it it definitely did
um I mean but you know people who have
not read your Memoir it's embracing a
piece of writing uh you had a very
difficult upbringing an abusive parent
but you were able to find your way out
of it one way was through music how else
were you able to find happiness and
stability
genetic inheritance that would give me a
predisposition to diabetes or heart
disease I had an emotional inheritance
that would give me a predisposition to
and happiness or abuse or addiction and
so for me what I realized is if I was
going to move out at 15 I had to learn a
new emotional language I had to learn a
new way of emotionally relating to the
world so that I could have a different
outcome than the one that my family had
inherited that basically I inherited as
well so I started to get really focused
on behavior and I'm not really sure why
I had a gift for that but at 15 I
started writing and I started creating
behavioral exercises for myself when
we're growing up nobody ever talked to
me about mental health I would imagine
the same for you no one talked you about
mental health did they no it wasn't a
word it wasn't a word it wasn't even a
thing that we were thinking about so how
did you make the transition from I'm
going to leave my house at 15 to figure
out I need to do something with this I
need to help myself what was your
process in doing that
it's kind of sounds silly but I was
raised on a ranch and we had a rabbit
that was raised with chickens because
the chicken coop was a safe place and
this bunny thought it was a chicken and
it would Peck at its food and it would
kind of waddle instead of hop yeah and
it scared me when I moved out because I
was like what if I'm a bunny that thinks
it's a chicken because I was raised by
chickens how will I yeah how will I know
my nature if my nurture was really bad
and so I realized what I needed to do
what made me think about it was an
orange I was eating an orange and there
was the peel and I was like I spent all
of my time thinking that I'm the peel
I'm actually what's in the center of it
and so I started to devise strategies to
help me go down and in to where I
thought my nature was and stop
identifying so much with just my nurture
and you're talking about years and years
of processes but that was the first step
you're dedicating yourself now to
helping others and you said we can all
do this in terms of our mental health
but what is it that we can do what do we
need to know I think just knowing we're
all in charge of our happiness there's a
lot that we can do to be in charge of
our happiness and that's my job is to
figure out how to be happy and when I
put my happiness as my number one job
and priority ahead of everything else my
life really started changing and that
means I almost turned down my record
deal I got discovered when I was
homeless and I almost turned it down
because because I was afraid that again
with my emotional baggage God forbid
somebody like me get famous it's every
movie you've ever seen about any
celebrity and I knew again that was
going to be me statistically so I had to
have a strategy and so it was a promise
I made to myself that my number one job
would be to learn how to be happy
about that it's what I was writing about
yeah and then my number two job was to
be a musician and so I just never
betrayed that promise and that caused me
to make very unconventional career
decisions I took years between albums
which people hate in my job but it was
the right thing for me for my happiness
tell us about inner world the virtual
reality platform you created which when
you're on the ranch and trying to get
away and create behavioral exercises for
yourself definitely did not exist and
now something like it does you know what
really bothered me is that you know for
kids like me moved out at 15 definitely
an at-risk youth there was no access to
therapy mental health tools support
systems so what about kids like me what
about people like me that don't have
access we have to create better access
and tools that work with therapy but
also without therapy just in case you
don't have access so that's what I've
been spending the last 22 years
developing and with inner world we
finally just launched in November it's a
virtual community where you can have
peer-to-peer LED mental health tools you
broke the chain in your own life leaving
the ranch leaving your your childhood
and now you're you're a parent yourself
you've got an 11 year old case a boy
yeah what's it been like raising him I
love being a mom I messaged you too yeah
yeah I feel it's such a gift and I
really do think the healing of yourself
is the healing of your children it's the
best gift you can give your child is to
really be committed to your own growth
and healing because it never stops so
how do you explain this to him what do
you say to him to make make sure his
mental health is okay when my son was
little I would teach him about his
feelings I had a story called The
Rainbow Dragon where the rainbow the
dragon would turn different colors with
different feelings and it was the
dragon's job to get his colors to change
back to his normal color so starting to
teach emotional intelligence when you
get upset to stop take a breath then
consider an action so tools like that
really help
amazing yeah I can tell you're a writer
yeah you can't talk just I know I'm like
rainbow dragons yeah it's incredible
and you can see a special guided
meditation on our CBS Morning social
media pages and of course if you or
someone you know is seeking Mental
Health Resources you can contact the
National Alliance on Mental Illness
helpline that is
1-800-950-6264 or text helpline to 62640